how's it going red Wow welcome back to
skate it's been a while hey man ah let's
do some cool tricks it's been a while
check this one out I call this one I
smell my armpit dick yeah baby
haha what happened there in the
background I have an how are you today
see you later I don't see how this will
cause any problem I am watching Bob's
insides and I feel like it ha ha ha ha
oops Bob you a-hole ah bah
Bob make a nice diving Bob style
IL IL no skating allowed this is my
tongue wait until I get ya
I got you now [ __ ] where the
[ __ ] he go ha ha not in my town [ __ ]
what are you doing the big back here are
you shut up a [ __ ]
Oh get the [ __ ] out street trash Oh
[ __ ] get out the way get out the way
[ __ ] hey Bob is a badass what are you
looking at Oh
giving the skaters are like the funniest
thing I swear to God Oh denied what are
you doing man stand in my way
yeah yeah all right fine I'll go to the
skate park bit Bob catch
ah I wanted like to find my nest I call
this one that I don't know what to call
it
I'm a fish what fish oh my gosh oh my
thighs rub all up hello my long
telophase how my face
i'ma fix BAM [ __ ] on my face Bob you're
skateboarder design a haircut I keep
telling you I love Trey's so much I love
3/3 power
I love walls too oh no no I don't you
love me back wall no diving
you can't tell me what to do
[ __ ] gravity man gosh I never bother his
[ __ ] oh god that looks so nasty Bob
what are you Bob such a nice and calm
day nothing really special going on god
I was hoping that super would happen
come on you piece of [ __ ] just stand out
buck oh my god space
ah god Danny
my fries got off down this episode here
yeah I didn't watch it but like if you
don't watch it helps me out I always
make more I'll make more if you like it
just do it now okay cool love you best
stay awesome
you
hi mommy let me touch your balls man
come on man
really don't fight it oh I'll find it
come on where are they
bite your balls man come on really
oh I know you like it